michaela is in Kentucky hi Michaela
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave thanks so much for taking my
call
sure how do we help um so I'm 21 years
old and my husband is 25 and we've been
married two years and I graduate college
here in a couple of weeks so cool which
are the great empires accounting good
for you you finishing your masters or
just your undergrad I'm going to be
doing my masters after I graduate and
then also studying for the CPA exam
full-time and hopefully pass all exams
by October awesome good for you yes
Wow you're killing it thank you we found
a home that we loved because it's
move-in ready it's right in our price
range of nine six thousand dollars and
our realtor says oh it's gonna sell fast
so we want to jump on it and we're doing
really great financially right now but
we're really worried about number one
not being ready and number two a
possible recession hitting and not
leaving us with a lot of cash hmm Taylor
what's wrong household income right now
right now 35 came my husband but then
when I get a job hopefully another 40
right and that's an October right yeah
okay all right and so do you all have
any debt right now just student loans 25
all right so 25 thousand and do you have
an emergency fund or anything yet yes we
have a $4,000 emergency fund and then we
have nine thousand dollars set aside
that we just got recently from all of
the refunds and stuff that we were gonna
use for the home okay all right now I'm
gonna tell you something Michaela
because you guys are planners and you're
walking through and you're looking at
things right now and you've seen it for
what it is I think buying a home right
now would be a two step far ahead I
don't think you all were ready for that
just yet okay and now I'm and I'm saying
financially because you want this home
to be a blessing not a curse okay so you
guys have around you said you got four
thousand you got around fifty
about $13,000 right now if you're
serious about it if I'm you what I would
do is I'm gonna stroke a cheque of
13,000 toward that 25,000 in student
loan debt okay keep your thousand-dollar
emergency fund and you guys keep renting
and stay focused and it's just too soon
to buy a home right now okay based off
just that one income however once you're
done with school and you guys now you've
got another income coming in and you
clean up the rest of the debt and have a
down payment is then you're gonna be set
so it's just gonna be about pausing and
delaying it just a little while and I
don't care what that realtor said about
it's a great deal it's gonna be gone
young lady you're gonna hear that about
a lot of things you don't want to make
emotional decisions you want to make a
business decision so here's the thing
everybody tells you to buy a house
aren't they
buy house by house by house by house by
house no one no one has told you not to
buy a house everything my mom doesn't
think so
we showed because of the recession
possibly coming okay all right but in
general yeah I mean I don't think
there's a recession coming it's going to
affect your house or so I disagree with
there on that but in general everybody's
a fan of you buying a house but what we
figured out with 30 years of sitting
with couples just like you guys is that
if you will be debt-free have your
emergency fund plus a down payment and
you buy the home your story when you're
35 is completely different than it is if
you've got twenty five thousand dollars
of student loan debt hanging around your
neck and then you go buy a house so I do
want you to buy a house I just want you
to own the house I don't want it to hone
you what's it going to cost for you to
finish school and do you have the cash
for that so we could use the cash for my
master's instead of to pay for that
upfront instead of putting it there we
go that's what I'm going to do the first
rule of getting out of debt is don't
take any more out and then the second
rule of getting out of debt is to pay it
off smallest to largest in that order so
let's stay out of debt in the future not
add any problems to this and so really
what we're saying is is that in a sense
you would be borrowing on student loans
in order to put a down payment on this
house because you used your money that
you should have used to finish your
masters to buy a house you couldn't
afford mmm because you're jumping the
gun you're going to soon out of the gate
and nobody else is gonna tell you that
but Chris and I are gonna love you
enough to tell you the truth we want you
to have a house but you're gonna make a
completely different house decision when
you have no student loans both of you
are employed and you've got your
emergency fund and place bless your down
payment you're gonna just feel so much
wiser because you will be hmm that's a
that's so true Dave I mean and and it's
amazing and we do have to be careful
because there people's opinions can try
to get into weight you know and and you
want to be clear about your game plan
and about what it is you're tracking
down and I'm proud of what you guys are
doing you're very young but you're
focused and that kind of focus is what's
going to lead you to progress financial
a down the road I mean when you're 27
the to a year gotta look like you're 37
to 47 and your finances because you're
so gonna be so far ahead now what I do
want you to do is this McHale I want you
to stay on the line and Kelly I'll help
you wanna make sure you get signed up
for that 14-day free trial and financial
peace as a matter of fact I'll just give
you a one-year membership to that okay
won't be 14-day free trial let's just
give you the membership because the two
of you're starting out together and if I
had known the stuff we teach in that
class when I was 21 I could have avoided
a lot of pain because every time I did
something stupid it brought pain into my
life